fear comes from the doubt  so the doubt becomes the cause of the  fear  which is the cause of the anxiety etc  the doubt is the cause fear is the  effect  what is the polar opposite to doubt  understanding  it's understanding  that's the opposite of doubt  so what is it we want to understand well  if it's me that's entertaining doubt  why am i entertaining doubt  if i were to find out who i really am  and i believe everything that's been  taught down through the centuries i  would have no doubt i would be realizing  that i could do anything  and the only thing that's caused the  doubt is a lack of understanding so i'm  going to keep studying and i'll gain a  better understanding i don't doubt  myself i don't doubt what i can do  um does that mean that i can do  everything no when doubt appears i'll  eliminate it